once cargos podrían caer sobre jair
bolsonaro según avanzan miembros de la
comisión del senado brasileño que
investiga la gestión gubernamental de la
pandemia entre las acusaciones las de
homicidio y genocidio indígena
incriminación apoyada por la orden de
abogados de brasil que señaló en un
escrito ante la comisión indicios del
supuesto crimen cometido por bolsonaro
contra pueblos indígenas por no cumplir
con la provisión de suministros básicos
a la población durante la crisis
sanitaria los letrados apelaron a la
definición de genocidio recogida en el
estatuto de roma sometimiento
intencional del grupo a condiciones de
existencia que hayan de acarrear su
destrucción física total o parcial los
señalamientos por la desatención de
salud pública se sumen a la crítica a la
política de desprotección de las tierras
indígenas en la amazonía para su
explotación agroindustrial y minera la
búsqueda de justicia trasciende las
fronteras este martes la organización
austriaca alright anunció una denuncia a
bolsonaro ante la cpi por crímenes de
lesa humanidad la ong estima que la
repercusión sobre el aumento de la
temperatura global
amazonas provocará la muerte de hasta
180.000 personas en los próximos 80 años
el presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro
está destruyendo la amazonía sus
acciones nos amenazan a todos hoy el
planeta contraataca acusamos a bolsonaro
ante la corte penal internacional juntos
haremos que rinda cuentas
esta sería la cuarta acusación contra
jair bolsonaro pendiente en la corte
penal internacional todas vinculadas con
supuestos crímenes eco sociales por lo
que se espera que se estudien todos los
cargos como un mismo caso